yeah so today I'm going to talk about
I'm the I'm the director of the group so
some ways I get the soft feeling I
sometimes get to talk about out of these
people's research and it tends but this
one is a project that I i really liked
because there's I think there's some
glaring omissions and where the industry
should be solved this this talk we'll
talk a little bit about it but like
Michael said this is a slide to sort of
show you what autodesk does because oh
there's a lot of stuff in this slide
autodesk came from the world of AutoCAD
that was to you know success by through
2d drafting tools right and then the
world sort of became our the software
became capable of supporting 3 3d so we
do the range of stuff from designing
cool cars to software to design
power plants consumer products buildings
in the upper corner I actually got into
this sort of sort of through a funny way
that I was doing user interface design
and interaction techniques and get
involved with this little company called
alias that wanted to use my interaction
technique to help animators do Adam
animation and ended up sort of on the
blue media and entertainment side of it
and that's what the octopus face guy
represents uh I actually was part of the
the Maya are led the Maya 1.0
development team so if you want to blame
me for features early on that's I'm the
guy to talk to it's a little bit late
for changes though at this point we're
sort of beyond beta anyway so the big
four monitors I'd say we help people
imagine design and create that's sort of
the company thing that you say but I run
the research group and it's actually I
think it's a very cool group because we
span a bunch of different areas and
actually i think a year or two ago my
friend told the girls man was here and
he talked about a lot about the user
interface research group and the stuff
that's been going on there so i decided
i would not talk about that again and i
would talk about some other projects
that are going on and you can see
there's a range of stuff on the upper
left hand corner is sort of weird thing
we're looking at bio life sciences work
obviously think lots of work on design
and fabrication how do you fabricate
things some stuff about sort of the
Internet of Things which is the
environment and also air ganamos
research
the neat thing I always say about that
is that we have these really
sophisticated for tools that design
things for humans to use or to be part
of our to live in but we have no
fidelity model of a human in these
systems at all like I can design a
version of this chair digitally do a
highly detailed model but I can't get
one piece information about whether it's
comfortable or not so that's really
about the basis of some of our economics
research it's more about can we you know
describe parametrically the
characteristics of a human being so it's
a really cool project um we're also
known for simulation graphics research
because we come from that sort of
graphics background one of the guys in
my group has a couple of academy awards
for various different special effects
fluids and stuff like that and one of
the secret sauces of our research group
is we actually have an explicit research
transfer team that's a set of really
crack developers who can take ideas that
come out of research and sort of push
them further along and either produce
something that's product ready or
something that's like some component
that a product team can really use and
serve as sort of the guys who are that
on call twenty-four-seven to make sure
that people using this stuff are happy
the stuff that I'm going to talk about I
think is one of them weird about this
point of articulation and time where
computer-aided design might be changing
and I think it's an important topic and
it's a sort of overlap between a
computational fabrication and changing
the way people really do design and
really redefining that relative to CAD
in a different way and so why is this
well you know my take on this is like
well we're sort of in this digitization
we're doing the process of digitizing
the making of things years ago when I
had more hair and stuff I used to play
and rock and roll bands and then all of
a sudden at some point people started
digitizing audio and for me it opened up
this whole world of like oh I should get
interested in computers because I think
I would be able to do a recording studio
you know much cheaper than having to pay
time in a recording studio maybe I could
do it with digital audio and it was a
very new thing turned out that was right
and the digitization of audio really
you sort of change things right I also
found out that analog is super great too
but but I you know the way I pitch this
talk is you know this is what's
happening the world of physical things
right and there's a good reason to do it
and if you look at the computer industry
and I gotta admit you know I'm not like
sort of patriotic or a person or but you
know I'm actually really proud of the
computer industry because like when I
started like nobody's walk around smart
phones and stuff and people would say oh
you do that computer thing you use that
IBM computer at the University and now
you know my mom uses an iPad and stuff
like that so we've done really well like
that's good impact and I think the
reason that they have is because we're
really clever about building systems to
construct systems so this you know this
is a typical slide where it shows like
look early computers with these sort of
hand assembled things like they're very
obviously you know component stuck
together and we develop these very high
level design tools and fabrication tools
to miniaturize this stuff to make the
whole process of making them a lot more
better and a lot more efficient and its
really paid off we've got some sweet
deals along the way like Moore's law but
you know that sort of approach to it
this very systematic approach is paid
off really well unfortunately in the
broader world physical things this isn't
as true but I'd like to help it along
and so the sort of the thesis of the
talk is well what you really want to do
the good stuff is you know if you
program the physical world in the same
way we program the virtual world because
that's actually very nice the physical
world is all messy and dirty and tough
and that that is a lot of fun but
there's a lot of great aspects for
digital control of things and use
computer science people understand that
and that's what we're seeing going on
with 3d printing right some of the fun
and the goodness and the power of 3d
printing is because it has those aspects
and like the computer world it's really
you know changing like who's capable of
manufacturing things are fabricating
things where they can do it you know you
don't have to go like like literally you
know we go to this little office used to
be somebody's office and we 3d print
something as
posted going to a special room because
we're going to mix plastics and stuff
like that so literally in that small
example where the where has really
changed also what you're capable of
fabricating has changed I could never
before in my life build a plastic
enclosure but now I've built several of
them and I had some my own personal
projects I readily you know I'm quite
well skilled in that so that has really
dramatically changed and finally the
real just the talk I really focus on is
like how how the act of designing and
fabricating is is going to change and
this is the cost example that I show
like when we brought a summer intern in
and we said okay your first project is
like you don't make a little stand for
your pencils and of course in the old
days you'd have maybe go to Home Depot I
guess and you know get some piece of
wood and a drill and drill some holes
right but now she just did it on her on
her computer then print printed it out
and augmented with some electronics so
she'd know what pen was in and stuff
like that so really the every that's a
really good example of all of all those
things that are changing in that formula
so the obvious key agents have changed
right 3d printing is enabling people who
couldn't fabricate before to fabricate
things I'm going to talk a little bit
about what is buildable is really
changing in some pretty exciting ways
and finally what I'm trying to do right
now is change how we design things so
this brings up the sort of computer
science notion of programmable matter
and you know the rise of 3d printing is
done really well I mean you can create
objects that you really couldn't create
before arguably we're still at the point
the point where it's like okay most of
this stuff is sort of baubles the
trinkets and stuff like that we're not
really it isn't the magical fabrication
machine but we can all sort of see the
promise of it whether we can get there
is another matter but it's definitely
changed things and it's an enabled a lot
of things that made us think differently
about the way we approach fabrication
and creating things in general
typically people say oh it's the future
of manufacturing that's really not clear
actually tell the truth we spend a lot
of time thinking about this
manufacturing in volume is very
different than printing one bobble head
in plastic and stuff like that possible
much more challenging you know yet to be
sort of solved uh and you know when you
talk to many factories about 3d printing
you know they don't they're not so much
to looking to replace existing
manufacturing processes but maybe be
able to manufacture something that they
could not manufacture before using 3d
printing now might be in another's
dilemma argument would be that while
it's clearly inferior right now over
time like the bullins of moore's law
will make 3d printing far better at what
it's trying to do and eventually or take
this are you claiming that 3d printing
is actually just aiming at something
completely different didn't us will
never overtake it no yeah I mean I think
we're going to get a Moore's Law effect
eventually it's it's just that it's not
you know you saw the stock prices as 3d
companies really shoot up I think sort
of based on that sentiment and you know
we're initially sort of pass that
honeymoon period but I think eventually
we are going to get there we are going
to get that sort of economy of scale and
I see that happening with our simple
MakerBot's at work you know we like so
to use them because they're there
because we have six of them you know for
all these reasons we just even though
it's inferior to a molding or something
you know and that eventually will just
be you know that'll that'll push a lot
of the manufacturing processes to to
change and you've probably seen videos
of people who've done you know fusion
basically we have these railway tracks
of 3d printers and stuff it's so there's
ideas on how to get all that stuff to
scale up so there's you know there's
there's no strong physical reasons why
that can't be the case there's just a
lot of practical stuff and momentum of
manufacturing industries to keep on
going just you know like well uh huh the
classic example we have is like we're
doing a we're making I really we're 3d
printing a bicycle a racing bike and I
always tell the team well you picked a
bad example because they're so refined
oh it's a hard time for us the designer
a racing bicycle that is lighter than
the existing racing bicycles because
they've hundreds of years of making
these things like so Manufacturing's
like that manufacturing processes are
very refined right the crank out volume
you know and stuff like that but
eventually you know I think they'll have
a pretty significant impact we see a
like on classic example is in people
making up jet fuel nozzles for airplanes
they do it because they can do it faster
than the traditional process and they
can make jet fuel nozzles that are more
efficient than the ones that they
already have on the planes and
understand them more carefully so we're
seeing already seeing these sort of
high-end adoption of 3d printing but if
it people don't need anything that's as
good as the manufacturing process a
actually introduced now it's like okay
yeah you've got this really high
resolution thing but like to print a
spoon it doesn't need to be that great
that kind of crazy like that may or may
not actually be the case with most
manufacturing down the road I don't know
yes because you know I sometimes think
that consumers need the more
sophisticated thing because if you if
your manufacturer you have specialists
who can work with metal and stuff like
that but to print three to 3d print
metal is very complicated even in a
specialist did it so you know you need
to really have a consumer eyes version
of that because it's like dangerous
there's a chemical symbol you know sort
of sort of thing so there's there's you
know there's just a lot more work has to
be done to get those things that sort of
that cut the consumer loans not they're
going to come from the bottom up you
know sort of thing or at least not not
as easily yeah so that's in the
industrial manufacturing but you know
there's great there's great promise with
in 3d printing itself that you can get
just different behaviors out of
materials just just based on shape
here's just some simple examples like a
lot of work that's done with mesh
materials to get a particular
flexibility by printing out lattices and
these are things that you know you could
not manufacture sort of in any other way
right so that's really the key and we're
starting to see that too that's the
classic example that you use for metal
3d printing that's a titanium hip cup
with a lattice pattern i'm mike
stop at last pattern that bone really
likes to grow into it and has enough
space so that you know veins and blood
supply can exist then people get those
implanted every day so the 3d stuffs
getting getting used and there's lots of
design things that you you know if your
mechanical engineer or machinist like if
you look at that last work inside of
there you'd probably say there's no way
I can machine that you'd also say how
the hell do I test that I've no idea how
that particular thing behaves it's not
part of the engineering you know and and
books but that stuff will eventually
come so i think the real juice is here
is when we combine that sort of thinking
what sort of new materials we can work
with and this is just a typical example
you look at the space of materials
there's a bunch of new things we can do
not only with the microscopic shape of
things to get different behaviors but
also with the materials themselves we
can we can have different behaviors
within the materials crossing examples
we were working with lawrence livermore
developing a crash crash helmet which
has different materials for high speed
crash versus low speed crash so like
tiny little hairs some of them collapse
based on high speed stronger ones for a
lower speed with different densities and
so in the world of manufacturing you
sort of deal with materials you know
like if you're working with aluminum is
one consistent thing but in the world of
3d printing you can print varying
amounts at microscopic levels so you can
have these very sophisticated designs
where material let's say varies across
the object that's your building and we
don't really have any tools that do that
readily there's not a lot of signs so
that's all this stuff is being developed
but it will be in enablers to do a lot
of super cool cool stuff plus there's a
lot of different things that we can
print right we can print a carbon fiber
right that's actually pretty
straightforward we can print fiberglass
we have fiberglass printer up in Toronto
and stuff like that and you get really
really strong 3d printed parts it's
completely surprising and of course
there's the issue of scale like people
talk about and people have already sort
of printed 3d houses or huts and stuff
like that so there's the whole sort of
mindset of basically
uh you know automating a fabrication
process is considered to be 3d printing
yeah progress in terms of the materials
being sustainable like stuff not
imagining 3d printing it's a way to just
create a bunch of extra stuff that we
throw away but actually people somehow
it we use the materials again yes I mean
there's some nice work like in you can
recycle some of the plastics they can
like with the with the pli plastics you
can reuse them like three or four times
over and over again actually we know
working with a little bit with the
starter company in Toronto who has this
grinder plastic grinder that you use
with your MakerBot and we're actually
really successful in schools because it
teaches kids sort of the recycling
sustainable thing but overall like I
wouldn't say like oh yeah the industry
is focused on that now they're just like
let's just get this stuff working then
we'll figure out what we do with that so
and I don't think is in there's not any
sort of magic there's nothing like yeah
I see your point like we may be able to
get into into some materials that are
biodegradable because of that and we are
sort of experimenting with that like we
did this one project where we made
building bricks out of girl growing
mushrooms with in forms and so you can
make a building on it this stuff is very
pliable and you can work with it lay lay
it up like bricks and we did this
installation at the the MoMA in New York
City it was a fairly big structure like
25 feet high or something and 20 feet
wide and then at then at the end of it
you just took all the bricks and like
just threw in somebody's garden and
ground them up and they're gone because
they're essentially mushrooms and straw
the mushrooms are eat straw to they
become fat like bricks and and then we
radiate them kill it kill it kill them
and after a while they end up in though
in in a garden rather than a landfill so
there's people looking at that so yeah
so it's kinda interesting if you sort of
look at what's the range of things that
are programmable on I really I'm the
only guy in the world who likes this
graph but
you know you look at things that like
things are either small or large in my
world and normally we build things out
of components like bricks lumber and
steel and stuff like that and you know
we assemble those things into buildings
and vehicles right that's a traditional
sort of in my world sort of the AutoCAD
world of making stuff and those actually
get assembled into cities and factories
and this you know when you start to look
at this like the Internet of Things and
self-driving cars that sort of a layer
layer on and apply to this sort of way
of looking at the world and down at the
bottom of course you have the
microscopic versions of those amid the
material science and alloys and stuff
like that that we were talking about
this arguably is the non-organic world
as sometimes say that's all the dad dead
stuff although it kind of pisses off
everybody that's working on that side of
the graph when you talk about their
materials being dead but this is the
non-organic and there is a whole organic
side to this and you can look at it in
the same way at the very bottom there's
like molecular design DNA viruses
bacteria you know and those assemble
with the cells and tissues and those
into organs and limbs and organisms and
then to Ecology's themselves whoops
jumping for the last one anyway so uh
you know I think of all those things as
candidates for design that's why I like
this graph so you can think oh can we
make design tools I'm going to apply
some of the things from one side to the
other etc in the world of designing and
creating things and the answer to that
is yes whoops let's see if my slides
need to catch up here there we go this
is great book biology as technology and
it really points out that you'll by
biology becoming a more predictable
science right we can specify certain
processes and given results right I'll
bunch of stuff we don't understand too
but there are some things that we can
sort of treat as engineering tasks and
literally as building materials and you
know you sort of see this in the popular
press right like we did a project this
company called organovo and they looked
at sort of what i refer to now is the
classic thing oh you know 3d printing of
living tissues and stuff like that
but but literally it's sort of a
manufactured manufacturing process our
fabrication process being applied to
life sciences there's a little bit more
subtler examples and my group really
latched onto this one which we thought
was interesting on a number of accounts
this is a wonderful world a lot of the
wonderful work from the visa Institute
from Shawn Douglas and George church and
what they did is you know you can you
can design small physical things using
DNA you can program DNA a DNA sequence
in a certain way such that if you
sequence the DNA and allow it to
self-assemble you can get structures of
certain shapes like they can do a right
angle turn or a little spiral and stuff
like that so basic geometric shapes so
what they did is they this research
project was correct was to create these
little things called nanobots and
nanobots are these small little clams
right clam size structures that float
around in your blood blood blood stream
and when they come in contact with a
cell there's a particular geometry on
the outside of it the clamshell opens up
and that's what you see here on the here
in the right the right hand side and on
the inside of the clamshell are the
enzymes that cause a cell to shut itself
off and so the little red things there
are these keys that only open when it
comes into contact with the cancer cell
and so that we thought hey this is kind
of cool these guys are building these
tiny little machines these mechanical
machines using this weird building
material DNA and they're actually
getting results that kill cancer cells
and the the funny thing about it was
that we were like hey you guys are super
geniuses why are you talking to us and
says well we're using Maya to do this
and it's like really complicated to use
I like wait a minute you guys are like
manipulating DNA to try and cure cancer
and you're having trouble using Maya
either you're like we're really bad user
interface designers or there's something
going on here but it just showed to me
you know the power
of the tool right these guys are saying
yeah yeah we want to do more it takes us
a long time we need a better tool and
and so yeah they literally showed us
they had a plug-in that they had built
for Maya the sort of CAD version to
manipulate DNA you know as the geometry
and then at the end of the day they
would like print out the the DNA
sequence and send it off to China to be
sequence get it back heated in a test
test tube shake it and look under a
microscope and they would see these
micro structures throw them in a petri
dish with some cancer cells and it would
kill cancer cells turn turns out that uh
i think the liver also kills these
little guys too so they're working on
that now but anyway my whole point here
isn't that it's a great medical example
which it may very well be but that you
know this is fab this is a fabrication
paradigm that you know within autodesk
we're all familiar with oh you're
designing your printing and stuff like
that but using of you know very
different materials now if you look at
the world of biology what's going on and
this is from by ahmad 2013 and you know
the funny thing is these things that
were at one time these sort of high-end
things are now becoming these sort of
you know almost like the robotic
building competitions where if you see
the byline there it says by ahmad is a
design competition which undergrad teams
compete the master control of
biomolecules and a nanometer scale so
they're fooling around with this stuff
like it's building belongs right uh and
it's not you know like just a few
high-end PhD students that you know
Stanford MIT stuff like that you know
there's these events where they get high
school students and stuff and people do
legitimate projects of oh I've built
this bacteria that when you shine a
light on it starts turning left and
turns left until you know you stop
shining a light and so their engineering
with this stuff readily and they need
tools and so with this stuff all
reminded me of the early days of the
computer world where you know had people
fooling around with computers sort of in
their dorm room or at home these
homebrew Computer clubs and news image
from 2015 this is somebody's dorm room
and they have like an autoclave and some
stuff so there's this yeah this sort of
parallel going on this stuff is starting
to rise up and starting to feel like
that paradigm that were used to you know
the computer world and also from the
design mechanical world so hopefully
it'll give you an idea that sort of the
range of things that we think we can
design with is changing so I'll stop
talking about that now talk about how we
design is changing i think this is the
one that is probably you know one of
them one of the most important ones at
this particular point in time so we joke
in our group actually an autodesk in
general that although we built this
industry computer-aided design the
computer is not doing a lot of aiding in
the design really what you're doing the
computer is forming as a means that once
you sort of figured out what the design
is you type it in to document and then
you use it as a communication tool to
show it to someone else and i was saying
to the folks at lunch sometimes use as a
litigation tool to describe to someone
that they didn't build the right thing
for you but the point is that there's
not a lot of smarts coming from the
computer to actually aid you in the
design and I'm always surprised this
like like the computers sort of the last
person the room to know that I'm
building this out of wood was two by
fours and it's like really I mean I
thought that was kind of the computer
was good at stuff like that so but if
you look at the way we design things
it's actually even screw here because
suppose you're going to design this
turboprop blade right now you actually
have some do you have some requirements
for the design right you want a certain
amount of airflow and you will tolerate
only a certain amount of noise coming
off it these are of course completely
simplified but it's just for the example
here so state of the art is this right
you take a softer like Autodesk Inventor
right hi in you know 3d modeling for
mechanical engineering and you build a
nice geometric model of the shape and
then you run simulations on it to verify
that indeed you're getting something
that's close to the requirements that
that you want right
and so what they say in the design world
when you talk to manufacturers yeah
that's the way work and you just you
keep on doing that till you run out of
time or money because you're on a
project or you can pay for it you have a
certain fixed amount of time so if
you're lucky enough you can maybe do two
designs or maybe even three and then
pick the best out of the two but that
does not happen all that often actually
in the design world so people are
generally are just going straight
towards what is a good enough design
that meets their meets the requirements
but it's it's really strange because
what you're doing here ultimately zere
trying to maximize or minimize some of
the attributes of the problem and
there's additional constraints you want
to build this thing so it fits on a
quarter inch shaft so it fits within a
four inch space that's the real
requirements for the design not the
shape right I think that's a thing that
freaks most people out it's like well no
but when do I program the shake no but
thats comes from the requirements and so
this site isn't this insight is not new
to us whatsoever I mean notion of
goal-directed design has been around for
a long long time ah and this is the
notion where rather than inputting the
shape of the thing that you want to
solve the problem you input the actual
goals of the design and the constraints
of the problem that you're working on
right then in order for this to work
hopefully the computer can automatically
generate potential designs and the
computer evaluates the designs to see if
it meets meets the needs so that's
pretty standard stuff so how would this
work well you saw previous example you
would like you get the computer to
generate 3d designs and then it would
pick the one that's most appropriate
right and the nice thing is how this
thing's sort of scales like if you have
more computer power maybe you do a dozen
right because you could test a dozen
within the time that you have allotted
to to do or even better right if you had
a really powerful computer you can do
thousands right or even better you could
do millions and probably approach what
is the optimal design given your input
now the
the thing about this is that you notice
that if we start out go back here you
know this is sort of you know close to
manual this is like the next one is this
is sort of deaths desktop works
workstation power you know powerful
desktop cry power right but to get to
this level of power and this sort of
thing you need like cloud computing you
need massive computing reasons re
resources but it turns out those are
sort of readily available and i'll argue
about that a little bit lighter so you
need a lot of compute power so what are
the challenges here beyond computer well
how do you express the goals it started
this user interface problem when you go
to designers and talk to them about well
you need to express your requirements it
can be very confusing as to what the
requirements are you automatically need
to generate the designs you need some
sort of generation algorithm right those
are you have tinkered around in this
area you know yeah there's like genetic
algorithms there's different ways of
going about these things and then you
need to evaluate it in sort of a
systematic manner so that's all though
it's hard but the good news is that this
approach has already worked in a couple
of cases and sort of really dramatic
cases so this was the radio and 10 of
that NASA used from 1960 up to 2000 on
on most of their space spacecraft
somebody had NASA I had a really nice
idea where they where they said hey why
don't we like design a program that
randomly generates antennas and then
we'll just evaluate which one is the
most effective on and we'll run this
like crazy on like a super computer and
then it'll pick the most efficient one
and they did it and they found out this
strange design the design that's on the
the right which looks like no human
would design it unless they're into like
elk or something like that it's 90 proof
you know it's ninety percent more
efficient because that's what the what
the computer you know found right and
the thing I really liked about this and
you know I sort of claim like this great
intellectual inside for about dare to
it's like oh it's changed the design
problem into a search problem
ah but it's somewhat did now the thing
that's almost kind of laughable about
this is you could you know in the middle
of the graph there that's the computer
that did you know the antenna problem
right but you know your average consumer
has more cycles available or a CPL horas
bubble on the amazon cloud right now or
actually as a couple years ago 55 years
ago so we really have this a lot of
compute power available to us so that's
sort of the good news is that
technically I might be possible right
the other thing I think they really
Drive this here is that there's
something correct about this approach
like if you think about the early days
of flight that's what this slide is
supposed to show when people try to
think about how to work on the problem
of flying lots of people build things
that look like you know birds so they
started to find the problem in order to
fly we have to be like a bird whereas
the Wright brothers and others kind of
thought no no we need to provide a means
of lift of means of control and it means
a thrust so they really got the they
really got the problem requirements down
correctly and at that point it became a
simple matter of solving that constraint
problem but I think I think you get the
point there's something about this
notion of oh yeah you're actually when
you're designing something you're trying
to get a good definition of the problem
and the requirements to solve it so in
our research group we thought okay let's
like try and build a system like this
because there's nothing like trying it
to find out that's not going to work so
we said well we didn't say this guy was
heading the project said let's do a
motorcycle swing arm because he rides
really fast motorcycles and I'm
surprised he's still alive so there may
be hoping in my group Dana but and it's
it's it's such a great case because it
is a vast array like any design space
it's pretty massive right there's a lot
of different things you can do with a
motorcycle swing arm and this is
actually sort of the way that designers
work now is they're aware of all the
prior work and the requirements they
sort of knit things together to come up
with a particular design but if you
break the problem down into its
requirements right the motorcycle swing
arm holds the back wheel onto motorcy
provides a way for suspension the law
the wheel to move up and down has
provisions so that you can have some
sort of drive mechanism like a chain has
to mount you know to the frame or to the
motor in a certain manner so those are
actual design requirements you know and
we can express them in a user interface
and this is a simplified version of it
as these simple you know sort of these
are the forces the stresses and strains
that this particular piece has to be
able to survive and plus roughly we know
it has to be within this volume of space
right so there's a basic sort of shape
there now that you know that stuff is
already sort of new and that's the way a
lot of structural engineers work
nowadays they design problems like that
the thing I think is really important
now is that we if we start to include
things like possible materials and
possible methods of fabrication the
computer can be a lot smarter because
there's one thing that we know in the
from the design world is that you tend
to have a design model that you make and
you verify and then you have a
fabrication model which is like okay
given that we're building it this way
you know how does the model have to
change and I think by combining the two
we sort of get all the constraints all
requirements in one shot we let the
computer figure it out that sounds
reasonable 22 to me so this is the slide
of the computer figuring it out this is
just one particular design and I think
you saw running before at all the next
slide shows some variations but it's a
pretty typical topological optimization
approach for those of you who are aware
of that the computer just starts out
with this block of mass and starts
chipping stuff away till it either fails
order till it keeps on working and it
gets it finds many designs and you can
see from from here you know it still
leaves geometry where the spring has to
be connected to the swing arm where the
chain has to go through and it generates
thousands of these swing arm designs so
we sort of have the basic plumbing of
that working what I was really
interested in this is like okay get it
but are people going to be able to use
this thing I mean like this is really
we're
and so I literally took like our user
interface some folks from our user
interface research group and say can you
go join those guys on this project on
the dreamcatcher project and just make
sure this stuff is usable find out where
the designers will actually use this
stuff and so you know they they came
back and said yeah because the you know
the workflow does look different there's
obviously there's a strong can't process
that we call the inspire process where
you tell where you sort of inspire the
computer these are the requirements of
the problem and stuff like that and then
there's a generation phase you generate
a bunch of stuff ah and you find out
which which ones work but then there's
this extra step in there that's not a
parent is that designers need to sort of
look at all the generalized designs and
find out the trade-offs between them and
we found out that a lot of designers
even if they know they cannot use that
design to fabricated are interested in
all the Train trade-offs in Vault like
if I make this out of aluminum is that
going to drive the cost up or is it the
weight going to go up so that they want
to play around sort of luck in a
spreadsheet sort of way with that to
navigate through that design space so
the notion of looking at the space and
analyzing what's going on sort of is an
important user interaction with this and
then finally of course you have
something and you want to fabricate it
right and so this is a videos early
version of what this thing looks like so
we're not building any geometry there's
no like 3d modeling going on there is a
3d space where the user is user is
exploring the various trade-offs between
each design that they point to so those
green blobs there are the different
swingarm did this designs i think we had
like two thousand different swing arms
in the database or something like that
but you see they've been looking at
there's a different combination of
strength weight cost the volume of the
swing arm the time to produce them you
know and so designers want to look at
those and understand the training
trade-offs I I was always of the opinion
like listen they're just one like kind
of just pick one for me about you know
it's it's not you know design isn't a
complete science they're trying to
understand all the stuff they have to
work work with so
let me see if I go to the next slide
here so that was the first one and then
we did the second project where okay
that one is pretty easy to specify the
requirements for the swing arms all
right there's probably like a dozen of
them so he said when we do a real case
study okay let's like design something
from there are from the requirements for
a real real car and it turns out we
found this wonderful example for Formula
One racing is you can go to the safety
specs and it'll say the design
requirements for like roll bar and
safety cages and so we literally pick
that stuff up and that's what this video
shows like we go Google we find the
requirements this is this is very me
it's like can we show googling and
finding and there you are those are the
requirements so there's nothing magical
here your engineer you're doing this
already and there's a diagram then we
use a language called sysml to formalize
those and this is important because it
sort of looks like this sort of strange
language but Mechanical Engineers
already use this and sort of high-end
projects and you have you know you have
the basic structural setup you have the
requirements and you have the
constraints of the problem so it does
look a very very different beast and
then we're into the generation phase so
this is it generating some different
geometries and actually that was the
mock-up would within my asst it was sort
of cool almost like a decade later we
were we were using Maya sort of the back
end of this thing anyway so that's the
example from the requirements off of a
web page it generates a legally safety
rollbar cage for an f1 racecar that's
the one that sort of looked like it was
a sort of a normal one other algorithms
came up with other legal ones everything
looks all bony you know and that's just
because these algorithms just make
geometry that's bony we have some other
guys working another project to like it
make it look like it's made of an angle
iron or something like that but sort of
the the physical appearance of things is
actually very important I don't have a
slide for it but we did do one nice
project where we said look actually
shape is just a constraint so we did
this notion of we have a bicycle frame
in this particular shape and it was like
the super cool sweeping bicycle frame
and we asked the system to
no structure within that space that
would support all the loads at a bicycle
frame for the Sikh and the pedals and
stuff like that so we end up with this
crazy lattice structure inside of it
right that solves for all the stresses
on it but has a super cool human design
shape so I think there's a there's a lot
more to be done just on so the
aesthetics and shaped shaped side the
thing that's really cool is that we had
this classical bicycle problem that we
were fooling around with and these are
all designed by a computer and some of
them are very similar to what humans
have designed over the years and some of
them are really quite different so it
just shows that it's very pliable it's
almost like well let's just recompile it
and try it with this constraint and we
get a new frame design so we're building
some some crazy full-size bikes at the
moment to see if we can actually you
know automatically generate a bike
that's lighter than you know sort of
manmade one of the hundred years of
refinements on it ah so that's a story
of that dream catcher project and so so
hopefully you know I've sort of argued
that there's some hope this stuff is
sort of enabled by this notion that you
know computing because much more
relevant when you can be highly coupled
to the fabrication process even more
couples if you can think of matters just
being strictly a programmable thing
right and but in order to do that
especially with this approach we need
massive computing but luckily that's
what cloud computing offers and it
nicely breaks down into this you know
easily computable problem the I think
from a design point of view really you
know it's really at the end of the day a
great product the the the design is the
design of the requirements right that
they've got sort of all the things that
make you really value the product and
that's that's what i sees maybe sort of
the hidden gem within all this work
besides just saving time i'm not sure
whether it saves time or anything but
that will get to a point where
essentially you know like with products
will be able to express the requirements
and say oh or you know it's slightly
changed let's just recompile the product
again and generate it
you know in aluminium or something like
that so I think that has I think that
will have a lot of power and the final
point is that i've sort of found out
that the computer doesn't care how
complicated it is right it's kind of you
know when you think about like what
happens in lon mechanical design you
have oh the structural team has done
their job then there's a wall and now
the thermal teams working on it and then
after they're done maybe we get the two
together and make them work but the
genius of nature this is sort of the
feel-good ending to the talk the genius
and nature's Nature doesn't care about
complexity there's no teams working on
this thing is so it comes up through
trial era these highly integrated super
efficient designs and it'd be a nice
trick if we gave computers to help us
with some of that right and I think
that's really what sort of ultimately
driving why you know why I like this
project why I'm pursuing it I don't know
if we'll ever get get there but you know
at least it's a good old college try
yeah so that's the end of my talk you
find out more about this stuff on the
Autodesk research site and I'm happy to
take any questions so it seems like at
first glance uh this approach works
super well for obviously Adventure
Center objective metrics that are easily
operationalized and probably not so well
for qualitative metrics or kind of
wicked design problems on the other hand
we also have probably really need tools
in the kind of crowd based space for the
kind of crowd source those questions of
you know is this aesthetically pleasing
is this XYZ qualitative measure to
people um do you guys think about the
crowd based approach or is there any
place in your view or yeah well yeah we
do sort of thing about I was telling
Michael that I was sort of thinking
about this stuff and I you know found
the soil and paper and started to look
at this stuff how we can integrate
there's a way that that integration
would make sense and what sort of the
state of the art of that stuff there's a
difference in time scale here right
because right now we're computing
thousands of designs in microseconds we
got away for some got crowdsource guy to
do it in 30 seconds
sucks sort of thing so yeah the jury's
I'm I don't really know but I think
there's some opportunity I'm a huge
believer in the successful approach of
course is the hybrid approach the best
of all sort of worlds so and also
fundamentally design is a very
collaborative process now things that we
showed here so you know computer sent
regrets it's you know it's terrible but
at least it's a viewpoint you know it's
it's a starting point for a piece of
research right so true I just follow up
on that question you mentioned the world
collaborative and so that's something
I'm quite interested at the moment is
how people in different places in the
world can work on the same sort of
project so you guys are you looking into
allowing some real time collaboration
between lots of people um actually
working on a model and do you think
that's a future that is that is the
future right uh maybe not thousands of
people working in real time on a single
model because that's you know that's
been they may not it may be not a
realistic problem but we definitely know
that let me let me just say like it's
almost being treated at all the test is
not are not a research problem like i
don't see that as a research problem is
more like okay what is the actual
requirements that customers have to work
in this this this this this way I think
we've we've gotten beyond sort of like
well it's the CAD model Ertz the thing
you know now well now we're starting to
look at it like someone said well no
it's more about the project right it's
not the model that's the project and I
think we'll just keep on going back
going down that and say well notice more
about the cluster of people or the
culture this work you know and sort of
work our way up whatever chain that that
is because at the end of the day if you
you know look at all of our custom cust
customers to general almost all working
in collaboration with other people so
they are already solving that problem
and I think we do a very sort of basic
you know basic job is supporting that
and not in any cat specific way we rely
on them to use whatever collaborative
tools are out there but i'm not i'm not
going to cite cat i think sort of all
collaborative tools or lowes
you know and this is really you know
this odd thing that we haven't really
nailed yet in the industry so yeah so
keep on working on it for sure cool
really nice talk I'm wondering if you
could talk a little bit so it seems like
the project keep dream catcher is really
trying to change the focus on to
generating the design requirements or
the user needs to provide the design
requirements by oh and kindle you know
have this much torture this much force
so I'm wondering have you thought about
like how do you help people generate
those design requirements or what do you
need so for example you show the example
of like you know the formula 1 racing
car obviously they've had structural
engineers and mechanical engineers
figured out like you know for safety
purposes when is it going to fail what
are these things but if you're you know
thinking about more end-user design or
something how do you yeah how do you
translate these engineering constraints
or how do you help people know what the
right constraints should be I'm
wondering if you know looking forward
obviously that's not what the guy
they're getting no we actually started
at that point um the original project
was pitched to me as basically that with
this natural language interface that you
could describe pretty loose terms you
know you're the thing that you're trying
to build like it's a table I want to put
flowers on the table and I'd worked on
natural lying you know speech interfaces
in the past and I just immediately drove
a dagger into the projects heart because
I'd been burned on stage so often by
speech distresses it didn't work however
they weren't there working pretty well
now it's not so bad so I think I over
overreacted so we did sort of have that
sense right from the beginning that's so
the natural expression of the design
requirements is a thorny problem and it
and it is luckily when we went out to
customers and started talking to you
know aerospace customers and stuff like
that they're already working in those
languages to express the requirements
right and so they do stuff like Oh given
the requirements it's not possible for
this this thing cannot be the physical
laws of nature do not allow this design
to to work so they're well down that
route so I think we sort of adapted the
strategy okay let's put that problem on
hold
the Restless stuff working with these
guys already don't have a problem with
that they can be very technical but
eventually you do have to come back to
that and i think that's that's one of
the maybe a really great user interface
problem here so but yeah to be to be
determined whether we take that on I
still don't think we take it on with not
natural language we also did some other
stuff where we just really cool the guys
did this thing where they just crawled
all the the best you know the best buy
web web sites and find out the basic
characteristics of op objects so we
could have dreamcatcher like build us a
TV stand just based on the basic
requirements are the basic you know
characteristics expressed on the best
buy site so there are some cute parlor
trick stuff like that and you know
didn't fully work but it sort of us
along those lines like how do you
completely get around that problem right
and so that that stuff is pretty cool to
read research too sure I'm should a bit
of the DNA application how far along is
like self-assembly going is it's a
totally different process right like
nature self-assembles and builds a plant
right we're still just putting things
together and rank them down yeah I
shouldn't mean the DNA one was I mean it
does the DNA does self assemble the
white DNA does self example but it's I
mean it's off-label uses of DNA for sure
right it is this sort of inert object of
DNA right there's no RNA they're
reproducing strands of DNA and stuff
like that how far along they on the
self-assembly we're just at the very
beginning of that stuff I think you know
not my area whatsoever but I mean people
are not so much looking at this stuff so
much in the assembly part as in the
production of different types of
molecules I can we produce a molecule
that takes in co2 and generates out
methane or something like that and those
are that's that I think the route that
sort of this the state of the art at the
moment but like I said you know not
really my area I'm just sort of looking
at it as a CAD guy saying something here
that looks like CAD that I can latch
onto yeah not to mention to yes so my
question is what is the current state of
tar that is being used and second
question is where we whatever
being an indifferent you well yeah the
state of the art for optimization we're
not doing too many super magical tricks
so and I would claim that topological
optimization techniques out there are
probably comparable to what we're using
we have a slightly secret sauce which we
think it's kind of clever and they may
help us but I think in terms of the
overall approached it like topological
optimization is only a small part
because I mean think about building that
part you you you want to optimize not
only for the topology but also maybe for
thermal properties for all these
different opt optimizes so I think it's
going to be how many things can use in
concert you know and also the things
that represent the fabrication process
so the the things to get writer things
we're trying to do is now let's kind of
get all the components that we need to
make this thing actually be useful on
the table as opposed to try and push the
envelope on topological optimization and
stuff like that although I mean there's
folks in my team that probably are going
to their sort of working on that
especially with regards to how it
interacts with fabrication stuff like
that but I really don't know enough to
eat details of that sort of your area
it's like no totally not my area so like
how did the competition like skill
number of constraints azhar like
exponential in the number 15 it's a good
question I don't know I mean um yeah
honestly I don't I don't know offhand um
I mean the good the good thing about
this approach is that um you can still
get results they're not fully exploring
the space is what we don't mention here
these spaces are huge they're probably
on computable even with the Amazon you
know my god even families on again you
know ah but you know we're doing a bunch
of tricks and that's okay right cuz we r
you know we didn't say we didn't
guarantee and optimized design maybe in
the future we will but at least we're
you know first set of rejects to reduce
the you know the the space and sample it
and send and stuff stuff like that but
to me as an HCI guy I'm like okay let's
just get some stuff from plumbing place
just take this car around the block and
see what it's like as opposed to let's
make sure it's generating 500 horsepower
and optimize designs because I don't
know if people going to want to use this
stuff I was proven wrong because when we
showed this to I could we showed it to
an f1 racing team and it was the
funniest phone call we've ever had I
just got to tell this to the store yeah
I've got a minute they like get on the
phone with us and that and they say look
we heard about project dreamcatcher
we've used every piece of software out
there we don't want to hear about any
commercial software we just want to
understand dreamcatcher and what you
know how far along you guys are are and
we only have a half half half hours so
start talking like I guess we found a
client you know you know so so I think
there's people that see they see the
promise of it it's a question of that
like let's just figure out if we can
actually use this stuff yet I think
they're sort of getting you know Holly
because there's some low-hanging fruit
here like obviously you know obviously
you want to solve different designs at
the same time you know in a separate
structural from thermal you know because
if you do it smartly get lighter things
that are you know you know that great
thermal properties super strong and all
the super material science fiction stuff
and dream catcher promises some of that
at least then that's the only way I know
how to get at sort of stuff like that
yeah yeah I'm very curious about the
trajectory through these design spaces
that the model takes and how that
relates you or doesn't play to what may
be a human designer might be doing is
has there been any it sounds like for
example to be the NASA antenna was
relatively like reports variably
permutation it's a very small problem
yeah yeah um whereas you know something
like designing bicycle enormous space
you know with even with just adding
separate several more constraints um and
I suspect that there are you know
behavioral profiles that designers have
that may or may not you know that these
these types of software tools may be
able to augment or perhaps even you know
give give us some insight into is that
something that people are talking about
or thinking about with something like
this we
well let's peek for result I may have
recognized so would you point that it's
like how do you see this space level
what is the computer cuz I right away
when I saw the demos I said like what is
it doing that wasn't doing nothing like
we're all the thousands of jobs and we
sort of realized just for practical
reasons like a little bit process dive
you need to restart we need to see it
did see the computer designing and
everything that it's doing but you bring
up a good point about we know designers
want to understand the space what
representations do we have the space
besides that characteristics and you
know here's your line through the
characteristics trade-off curve there's
typical Pareto curves and stuff like
that but I we are we are asking okay is
there's something else here there's got
to be something else because I mean
these things are very weird it comes
back and well I guess this is the design
I mean it does seem a little empty or
something so yeah I think that's a
that's a really good topic I know no
idea how to visualize these spaces
actually I mean just for debugging
reasons official line did we miss any
important spaces you know all right
let's thank our speaker one more time
you